[Music]
[Applause]
firstly
i don't have any apologies that i've
been made aware of any conflicts of
interest
so we come to confirmation of minutes
item 3.1 pages 16-38
i understand counselor barnet you have
some corrections you've
wished to advise what they are i simply
um emailed through a couple of tiny
corrections for spelling and so on
but also added the comment um in my
section
on the panel for the chief executive
appointment
that it was the most important decision
this council will make this term which
was not noted in the moment
okay
okay and there was one other adrian
there as well because it was wasn't
speaking to the amendment
because it was it's been the motion yes
so it was just correcting it all right
uh with that have i
someone prepared to move it though do
you wish to be there this trend correct
record with those changes council
members
seconded by council redmond i'll put any
discussion i'll put that all those in
favor all right
contrary to clear that carried will come
to 3.2
in 3.3 in public excluded
matters are rising you had an item
council
yes just to note that the submission the
ravenswood
plan change had not been notified in
time for this meeting
and it's now being notified this weekend
and
submissions close on the 4th of december
my question to the ce
is how we want to proceed whether we
want to do a submission and bring it to
the
december council meeting considering
that it's the first of december we do
actually have time to do that
given it is the first of december it
would be
preferable the alternate was going to be
circulate
and seek ratification but if there is
time then um
at this time that seems the most
appropriate
approach thank you
any other measures arising um i have no
deputations and presentations there's no
due to business so we come to item
six which is covered 19 recovery
planning
the first is 6.1 a report and mr cleary
and mr simpson mr oxbra please come
forward
it's pages 39 to 101
my understanding is you've got a new h
to circulate as well
colin is that right thank you
hello
so only h is new which is highlighted
so you don't need to read the full set
again so colon that
h is just being inserted in the other
resolutions remain so it's a new age
yes the others would then just follow
yeah
thank you so it's what's been circulated
here
thank you so this report is on the
funding of uh the projects receiving
government stimulus
funding um the purpose is to gain
approval of the funding approach
of these projects and this follows on
from the reports
at the 22nd of september meeting to
allocate the projects
and the subsequent briefing to work
through a few
of the funding options the outcomes
from this report will be to confirm the
budgets for the
different projects in the split of the
budgets between level of service and
growth
to confirm the scheme contributions
towards projects and
subsequent rating impacts and to allow
consultation to proceed on the basis of
those
two decisions and it also covers off
some of the earlier technical questions
that had been
raised through um earlier processes with
attached memos to cover some of
those questions off as well so i thought
i'd just work through
a few of the key schemes um this should
be
familiar from what was presented in the
briefing but i thought it would be good
to provide a recap
um so in terms of burnside to start with
this um project has a total budget of
about 1.3 million
it's proposed that there'll be a scheme
contribution of about
290 000 um
and a growth contribution of 125 000
and this would result in a final rate
okay final rate of about fifteen hundred
dollars per
connection per year so at the moment for
insiders
at about two thousand four hundred
dollars per connection per year
sorry to steve because it's quite quite
finding it hard to
hear
okay i'll carry on if this is any better
otherwise i'll just try to speak up a
little um
so just to carry on with burnside so
that would um
so there's a direct scheme contribution
and a growth portion
which gives the final rate and it's also
acknowledged that there would be a
future
sale of land from the wastewater
treatment plant site which would then
be given to the eastern district scheme
and also the account balance which would
go to the eastern district sewer scheme
and the other note on fernside is in
in order to cover the growth element
we're proposing that a
development contribution area or dca be
created
to ensure that any development within
that area pays their
required development contribution
uh logan lee we used a similar model
where there was a scheme contribution
a growth portion and that
would give the final rate for the scheme
so in that case the scheme contribution
was worked out at six hundred and twenty
thousand dollars
and the growth portion at just over one
point two million dollars
and that was worked out to give a final
rate for low bentley of about one
thousand six hundred and eighty dollars
which is lower than their current rate
of about
2 100 um
and again that reflects the savings in
them
them paying the eastern district sewer
rate plus also paying
their paying off their game contribution
on top of that as a loan
um we did in order to get a feel for the
balance of the options the alternative
options would have been
either they join the eastern district
scheme so they just pay the eastern
district sewer rate which would have
been
a very significant uh reduction in their
rates
and um was seen as an equitable
or a disproportionate benefit to a small
number of ratepayers
the other one we could have looked at is
holding their rates steady which would
have increased
to achieve that we would have meant they
give a bigger contribution towards the
project
but that would have come with some
[Music]
quite significant consultation risks
where we would be trying to gain
a community's endorsement of a project
saying that
you know it's good news we've got
government money to help fund it but
they
some of them might question why they're
not seeing more of a benefit of their
funding so we think
we've found a good middle ground of
giving them some benefit but still
reflecting their rates that they would
still be the two highest rated schemes
just not as high as they previously were
um in terms of points road we
there we're not proposing a scheme
contribution towards the wider
rate payer poll but instead a
contribution towards the west end and
summer hill schemes
is expected and that's an
acknowledgement of
the specific history between those two
schemes and the ongoing work with the
advisory groups there
and we've also looked at a growth
portion of that project to ensure that
new connections to the points road
scheme
cover a share of the project so we did a
proportional calculation
and worked out a growth portion of about
seventy one thousand dollars
um which would be recovered through new
connections to the points road scheme
and the extra recommendation which has
been circulated
was following on from our most recent
points road
advisory group meeting where um
[Music]
it was considered that as well as paying
off a share of the pipeline that they'd
be connecting to new connections on the
points road scheme should also help
pay off a portion of the second wall at
western which new connections to we
stayed in there would pay a share of so
we
that seems fair that new connections to
points road that would benefit from that
same project would pay a share to that
so that recommendation is just saying to
include that project and the points for
dc as well um
in terms of rating impact the the
projected
rating and increase for points road is
about a 50
increase rather than about 100 increase
the exact final amount will be subject
to the ongoing work with the advisory
groups when
a final figure is settled on in terms of
how much that contribution is between
schemes um so
but that's it's looking like it it's
going to be that kind of order of
magnitude
um
[Music]
we're not proposing a scheme
contribution
um partly because tawahiwi
is is not a standalone scheme it's a
part of the eastern district sewer
scheme so if we're proposing a scheme
contribution there it would have
effectively be
the wider eastern district scheme but
rather the benefit of this project is
that it will offer
operational savings to the wider eastern
districts ratepayers
and we've also allowed for growth
portions of those projects were
applicable so
in terms of wastewater not for the
central part which is addressing it
existing deficiency but for the
extensions of the scheme there are
growth
portions allocated for that
and one question that had been raised
was in terms of when you allow
a gross portion of a project it means
that council has to
cover that portion of the project cost
up front and then recover it through
development contributions so
if you set that too low you risk
developers not paying their fair share
of a project and benefiting
from the stimulus grant but if you set
that too high there's it
it could get to the point of council
taking on an increased level of risk in
terms of funding too much up front
that if the growth doesn't happen may
not be recovered
so we think we've got the balance about
right for that with um
the the amount of connections we're
expecting being
being relatively uh not
not too optimistic and not too
conservative and also the
resultant development contributions are
in line
with other similar schemes
and we also looked at in terms of the
amount that council would be covering
there's about 1.98 million dollars worth
of gross budgets
um so that is some additional cost
to accounts for council to fund but at
the same time we've removed 3.7 million
dollars worth of
budgets that we would have been funding
otherwise have we not had the stimulus
funding so the net effect is the council
is
contributing you know there's less
capital work than there would have
otherwise been
even though we're doing a lot more
projects than we had planned to do
just the final couple of points on
equity so
we equity is partly achieved through the
selection of projects where we've tried
to pick
a range of projects across the district
to give as
many rate payers benefit as we can
but also in terms of the residual
balance of the scheme contributions from
fernside and um
[Music]
love and lee we estimate 560 000
of this um these skim contributions to
be able to be allocated
evenly across the wider ratepayer base
and then i provided a summary
in table two of the the net effects of
of these scheme contributions as well as
some other minor benefits in terms of
operational savings of schemes
and also some other projects that have
that were going to be funded by either
eastern districts or district uv
being taken off the box provides the
savings and
the wider rate payer base no longer
having to fund these projects so the net
effect
if you look at table two for someone
who's got a water connection in eastern
district or
and the sewer connection is estimated at
about seven dollars per connection per
year
uh and just the final point i was going
to talk to before taking questions was
around delegation so you'll see
that there is um a couple of
recommendations
uh basically delegating to management
team
um to be able to move budgets between
financial years either if we're ahead of
schedule and we're going to finish
everything
before the end of june we would need
that whole budget within the current
financial year
um or also to manage the stimulus
package of works
as a whole such that if there's unders
and overs between projects given they're
all funded from the stimulus cost center
that um that we can have those unders
without having to report back to the
council each time so the example would
be one project
prices might be 50 000 higher another 50
000 lower rather than
lose a month or six weeks to to request
to move that budget
from council that we would report to
management team
instead and that's really just um
due to the practicalities of trying to
deliver this large package of work
in a short time and and trying to avoid
too many delays with that
um and we it's also noted that we'll
ensure that there's regular reporting
back to council
on on any other or on on the whole
package of works as a whole
to cover off any changes like that
so i'm happy to take any questions on
that
thank you khan doesn't do kelly or jared
bush to add anything
yeah yeah so i think the only thing that
um
kelly's just noted in the table and the
recommendations it's got the
points road dc that hasn't been updated
to reflect the change in
um and adding the the
um western backup well project to it
so that would be that would be an
addition so the points road
dc in the table under recommendation g
is two thousand and eighty dollars per
unit that's as a direct result of
contributing towards the new pipeline
part of the project
and then the contribution to the new
well at western would be on top of that
which i think is about
uh i think it was about six hundred
dollars for a two-unit connection
um yeah so so colin are you proposing
that that would need to change
from what's currently sitting here
certainly yeah so i i suggest that we
um in moving resolution
g um
say that we could put a
um approximately 2680
and then put an additional note in
that notes that staff will um
bring the exact figure for the points
road
development contribution to the
um draft annual plan draft ltp
deliberations for
a or resolution so that's okay yeah
so they're just dating that to g have
you got that adrian
celebration yes to the draft ltp
deliberations here
okay so i've got first accounts the
meetings followed by council duty
thank you
thank you council duty just my question
is
um as as we really haven't got to the
final figure
that that contribution will that be
sufficient
if it goes up a bit higher
um that will look it'll be that that'll
be
approximately 2 680 but because it's a
resolution of council we want to just
make sure we use the exact figure when
it comes to the ltp that'll be
that will be
just looking at the graphs of the
impact on rates um for points road
summer hill and west earth on page 5051
which are all using effectively going to
be using the same water scheme
um points road is sort of with the
stimulus funding is hanging around the
1000 mark
summer hill goes up to 1400 and keeps
going up
up to around 13 1400 and we set and
stays pretty stable
on around 900. why is summerhill so
disproportionately
different and why is it continually
increasing compared to the other schemes
who've received some benefit from the
stimulus funding
well probably a couple of points the
benefit it gets
from the stimulus funding is exactly the
same as for western which is the gap
between the two lines
in terms of why is summer hill
increasing which is from about years
three to six ish
that would i don't know the exact
project that would be triggering that
but that's
outside of anything to do with this so i
i guess that is one
point about this is that we can't
address
all schemes with high rates completely
with this project
that's that's probably a very good
question to cover in the ltp
with because that's what we're looking
at you know all schemes for the
10-year profile and beyond but i guess
what what is the feedback from the
summer advisory group when we see the
summer hill advisory group about these
figures have they given feedback about
these figures
yet and are they likely to accept these
figures well
the last time we worked with them which
was before going to points road
they they had a recommendation on on
what kind
what size the contribution from points
road to someone who invested and should
be
and then and we've got a meeting booked
in
a couple of weeks to go back to them
with we've since met with the points
right advisory group who've
recommended a figure that's slightly
different but similar
and then we're going to bring that back
to the west end of some of the whole
group so we'll get that for you so this
is
prior to the feedback from somewhere how
we sit in this as
we've had the first round of feedback
from them but we haven't had the second
this rate rating at the moment including
the points road edition
uh they they have recommended what's
shown on that graph
um the the contribution that's on that
graph
uh has been recommended by western and
summer hill
um what hasn't happened is we you know
that
we then took that to points road and
then it has to go because they
once we didn't say yes we agree with
that exact figure we're going to go back
to somehow when we see it and say here's
a slightly different figure
so what happens it's just that what if
scenario you take it back
and the the summerhill scheme people say
why is everybody else staying the same
and we're going up
how is that fair when these people are
getting a new service
how will that be responded to and how
will we deal with that uh so there's a
couple of points i suppose we
um there is a small project for summer
hell and we stand
each getting a small storage upgrade but
definitely not off the scale of
points road um and
i i guess the only other point is
that that really the way to make all
schemes
have the same rate or a more similar
rate is through a wider rating review
which is coming up
um that that's really the
the answer i think yeah that's not the
question i'm asking the question is
isn't this looking like we're giving
more to points road than we are to
summer
guess the point yeah colin would be that
if if there's a feeling of the summer
hill and i
understand council barnard's question
then that would be a matter that would
come to the ltp
these are going to go into the draft ltp
so that could be submission points that
could come from that advisory group
yep yes yep yep
okay council meetings with regard to the
summer hill
um with that summer hill graph i looked
at that as well and thought that's quite
you know i can see where you're coming
from christian but when we were
discussing that at the
points road meeting the other night did
you not say that that summerhill is
carrying a loan because they had
a couple unsuccessful um wells so is
that not
that that's what i thought those figures
were why why theirs are higher because
they
that scheme has a personal loan if you
will of
um unsuccessful for unsuccessful
but but but had it had it maybe been
smoothed
and and is is that
is there a product project in the works
or is this
just the um effect of smoothing from
their capital loan uh just as we've been
talking about that i've had a quick look
at the
summer hill budget so there is some
works proposed in
year 8 capital works which will have an
impact on it
but i think probably one of the main
reasons that it goes up and then comes
back down again
is because of what we were just talking
about the
rate smoothing so summer hill has had
rates moving
um undertaken on it when we've prepared
these graphs
we've just taken exactly what's in the
budgets sheets
as they are at the moment without any of
the um refinement or adjustment to them
so
they were purely just to show the impact
of the project
and what it was going to do so the
purpose of the graph was to demonstrate
that summerhill was going to
benefit by around about twenty dollars
um per yeah about fifty dollars per two
years
so yeah i think that would be helpful as
part of the draft ltp that we
give further consideration that i
remember being part of this
discussion when we were looking at the
upgrade and counselor meetings is
exactly right
we'll be carrying some of that but i
think it would be given the difference
it would be useful to have a further
explorer of that as part of the ltp yeah
and i can probably respond a little bit
more
just scrolling down um the head this
exact question i think came up three
years ago there had been some
smoothing applied to summer helen but
what it effectively means is their rates
now are slightly discounted
then they have to make up for it in
later years so three years ago that was
out
about six years now it's only out by
about three years we can look at that as
part of the atp that would be good
all right any further questions uh
council redmond
uh thanks colin on diligent page 58
uh 5.2.13 under to a heewee
um you say once a satisfactory number of
agreements have been signed the
contracts can be awarded
what sort of number are we talking about
what is the satisfactory number
i i think it would have to be in the 80
to 90
kind of thing like if we're if we've got
percent signed in the last um
you know half of them you know really
good
process and we're just getting the
paperwork sorted that would be okay but
if we had
um yeah so that's the rough number and
we'd have to have not only that a good
percentage sign
but a good good enough indication about
the rest
and maybe we could handle one or two
that might
be really tricky but not not 10 or that
sort of thing
okay any further questions is rick
sorry you have a question counselor
cleary
that is correct correct it's actually
not a question
but i could make it sound like a
question no that's all right
um just going back to recommendation
g um thanks for to
some speedy work from our chief
executive we can actually give you the
uh figure so it is um
instead of 2080 it is
2 7 4 9.
so um that amended resolution that i had
we can scrap that and just make those
edits
to the table in g um and that
that would be a suitable resolution
because it says
does that transparent that trip would
transfer into the total
amount as well so in both columns yes
so then wouldn't need the additional um
a piece added to g
is that correct so um council williams
you were signaling you're prepared to
move are you happy with
is has been suggested seconding council
duty
casa williams no i think we've all
looked into this for a long long period
of time and
i think it's good for the the whole
community so well done
okay council duty yes
i'll just read speaking about the points
road one
um we're making progress there so
and that was really the last sticking
one so
it's it's looking good and i really
congratulate the staff all the
hard work they've put into it so thank
you
any further speakers we should respond
i'll put the recommendation which is the
piece that's circulated so uh all those
in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carry
sorry yes it is two seven four nine
yeah thanks adrian thank you tabe
all right so
all right so now we've come to 6.2
cardboard stormwater and flooding
improvements so that's
kelly and jared i think you were very
quick and getting there
that's what seats
thank you thank you the purpose of this
report
is to obtain approval for the
proposed funding approach for the shovel
ready kaipoy stormwater
and flood improvements projects so you'd
be well aware that
it has a total budget of 18.13 million
nine million coming from the
government's trouble ready funding
and nine point one three million from
council
budget so that's existing budgets under
the kaiapoi
urban drainage account we
staff have had a closer look at um
the funding arrangements for this in
particular the proposed
um macintosh drain works which actually
have a benefit
beyond the kaiapoi uh urban drainage
rating
area and it's proposed that we
fund part of this from the district
drainage
account we also propose to
uh uh set up the
kaiapoi east north east development
contribution
area so that is an area just to the
east of sovereign palms
and we already have an existing
development contribution for sewer for
that area so it's effectively
um mirroring that and adding in drainage
as well
so the net effect of that is
that um the
kaipai urban drainage rate will increase
currently it's about 305 dollars per
property and will
increase to about 452 dollars per
property by
if we hadn't looked at um
recognizing that some of the benefit for
the macintosh drain works is beyond the
kaipou urban area
then the kuiper urban drainage rate
would have increased more potentially
by about another fifteen dollars per
property
in terms of the impact on the drainage
rate um
that will increase from about 16.85 per
property up to
17 um sorry 19.71 so a 2.86
increase in terms of the recommendations
probably just a few key things to note
so while we've got a total budget of
18.13 million
and we've given a a breakdown of what
those projects are within recommendation
d
in recommendation me we're asking for
the delegation to management team to
actually while not changing the overall
total budget of this package of works
provide the
delegation for budgets to be shuffled
within projects within the total
package but also noting that we'll be
providing regular reports back to
council on progress any risks
program financial status so you're well
aware of
where we're at happy to take any
questions
thank you questions no questions
someone prepared to move the
recommendation moved by
council rankings and secretly by council
blackie
councillor atkinson very carefully we've
very quickly
said carefully as well i suppose a lot
of money um
look we've came for the canvas to to and
from many many
um different forms around here this is a
great thing for
all of our community indeed our district
if the
when you pull the plug out and
everything goes down it someone has to
catch it
and uh the end of the bath covers and
kayak way so i'm very pleased to see
that the contributions across the
district
will argue about what level that should
be when we come to the district plan i
think
should be a good thing to have a look at
uh not the district plans or the uh
they'll tell you because we'll argue
this yeah we could go there as well um
but look this is this is work that's
going to have to be done and
will be done in the future anyway so
it's bringing it forward and yes it does
put pressure on
but it's the most sensible thing to do
in um in the stimulus
package that's off it so i hope you'll
support it
thank you casa becky yeah the next
excellent report guys
and i'm glad to see that you've been
thinking into the future with the
macintosh train
concept because that's going to come you
come up in the next couple of years
so well done you've heard the speakers
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor all right
contrary clear that carry all right
ceo did you have something here the
speed of the myths before
has created a slight
point which i think we could fix at the
ltp but
with your indulgence we could fix now
about that
dc for earthen that the total value
was correct at 669 but colin made
reference to the fact that that was for
two units
and this schedule is for just one unit
so we should
divide it in half and if that were the
case that would make the number
2415 rather than 2749 which
is better from a punter's point of view
but um
so either with your indulgence we could
we could
uh i mean that now or we just deal with
it at the lt
well by agreement are we all happy with
that so adrian you're happy to just
um just to adjust the minutes to it but
hey what's that
point of view just to amend that so
anyone opposed to that
all right consider that consider that
amended
that's okay all right
so let's get back onto the agenda
all right so i have no reports under
regeneration just
um next year regeneration will actually
proposing that that will probably be
removed from as a reported item
unless these items that come up but uh
there hasn't been for some time but from
next year on that'll
just move from the agenda just to let
you know that
uh um reports um so we come now to 8.1
which is uh david and rob
pages 159-179
proposed in these easements and terrace
road cast
thank you leading david welcome to our
table
afternoon yes it is going after all i
suppose after all some of the numbers we
just heard about this is
pretty um pretty low numbers it doesn't
mean that they won't engender a lot of
debate
[Laughter]
i was hoping i'm not saying it well this
time but we'll just never know yeah you
never know no you never know
now this is a fairly straightforward a
private owner has made application for
an easement for right-of-way intelligent
communications and other bits and pieces
across
what is currently a um what was a gravel
reserve
in the back of cust a fairly
straightforward application it's a
question of
council approval is required and the
applicant is paying all our costs
um including a compensation payment of
six thousand dollars to the council
which even though it
may be three years old it's still fairly
current in relation to where the market
may be
for this sort of transaction
they had a valuation of their own at a
thousand dollars
and my view was that it was totally
inadequate it was
founded on the wrong premise so as far
as i was concerned it wasn't acceptable
we told them so they came with the six
thousand dollars finally
so that's fine so it's up to the council
happy to answer any questions that um
anybody may have any questions counselor
edmond followed by council stuart
uh thank you from looking at the aerial
photograph
um the reserve adjacent to the terrace
seems to be occupied by the giles
folk at the moment from looking at the
aerial photograph
um do they have a license to occupy
and has any consideration been given to
disposing
of that portion of the reserve
when they're going to be doing some uh
subdividing work with their own son
division
i'll do the second question first
with preliminary discussions with we
have a currently have a
license to occupy to one of the
adjoining owners for the land
on the eastern side of the bend on
terrace road
he he got a five-year license
um on the basis that the ground was um
fairly well fairly rough actually
overgrown starting to get overgrown with
bremer gorse
preliminary discussions with him was
that he was fairly non-committal at the
time
when we raised the question of a
potential sale
however since that time with the
disposal and acquisition policy being
developed by the council
those situations would have changed back
when i last
discussed just with the individual
concern would have been back in about
february
and we hadn't really got that policy
underway it's a standard question we
then
we raise nowadays and to get some
interest if there is any in
their location the second part i'm not
quite sure exactly where you're
referring to counsellor of
the strip the actual strip between the
the boundary and the road
the yeah yeah yeah a long terrorist ride
yeah there is is that there's it goes
from on the eastern end of around about
35 meters
down the far end to nothing at the on
the western end
and it tapers right down they i think
you would find there's a bit of
adverse occupation but these things
happen in rural locations
so so i'm sure no there is no license on
there no
no i mean that that's a possibility we
could we could go down that line if we
if
if needed but possibly not needed and
just
to further answer your question and i
think council steward as well had
raised a similar question earlier which
we've responded to
the origin of this went back about four
or five years when the first inquiry
occurred
and i i recall and i may stand corrected
that gary did have a look at the
prospect
of offering it to sell to them they went
i don't believe they were overly
interested at the time
but also on top of that the costs of
releasing the property from the reserve
status
and the timelines around there were
reasonably significant
so in isolation that little strip didn't
seem to make sense from an economic
perspective
if in future years uh the adjoining
owner to the east
that is currently leasing or has the
license over the larger block
if both parties or in fact what might in
the future be
three or four parties we're interested
um the costs
of releasing the property or revoking
the reserve status
relative to the disposal revenue might
start to make a little bit more sense
but at the moment um we were probably
looking somewhere in the order of 12 to
18 months
to work through the process and in the
order of 15 to 20
000 for the costs associated with
removing the reserve status and going
through the investigations
just to follow up are we going to look
at
a licence to occupy them
in future for that weed shape area to
the south of paris road
once the easement is granted i can't see
them having any great incentive
to want to buy something they're already
occupied
yeah correct i think they've been that
any sale would be a discussion for the
future
um although there's benefit i would have
thought
for them or the individual owners at the
time to actually do something
when they then when that may occur and
your point raised
there's a fair comment in relation to
getting your license to occupy i mean
that could be a good way to manage the
risk to the balance of the land anyway
well that's liver
yeah correct cancer so you follow that
through
um i i emailed rob over this
because it came up um as he rightly says
um
several years ago when this subdivision
was first considered the question being
that is a long weedy uh infested
depression can we not give it
to that land owner because
it is absolutely redundant land um
i don't see that there is a value it's
full of weeds
and it is actually goes down like that
so the question as i said can we not
give it to that landowner it is
problematic in any shape or form
and to expect someone to buy it yep
can we give it you get them to debate
here but you made your point
yeah can we give it to them yes the
council could determine to actually get
uh gift that away however there is a
cost associated with that
up to fifteen to twenty thousand dollars
so that is the problem because
as soon as we do a survey there's
there's costs involved there's legal
fees there's all the other bits
we've got to get the reserve status
removed and that takes time
and effort to do that i mean the
contract could say no consideration with
the
purchasers being responsible for the
costs and that's the way this
agreement's
worked on the basis that the gillies
would be paying all the costs associated
including staff time to actually grant
get the
easement granted if that's what the
council is determined but
point taken of course casabana
just further to that the whole reserve
area there is absolutely covered in
awesome broom and it's absolutely just a
disgrace to council quite frankly
um why aren't we doing something with
that land to actually either
a bring it to a non-noxious weed
standard
or b getting rid of it so that we can
actually have someone make use of it and
look after it
wouldn't that make sense well as i said
there is a license to occupy on the
eastern portion of their
their block because the adjoining owner
he
had ahead of you exactly like yourself
that it's it's looking untidy it's
looking at a controller's agreement
broom and gauze and he i last time
talked to him would have been about
three months ago he's done all the
spraying that he needed to do
so that will come into control he
proposes to plan to have native
something like
up to four thousand square meters in
natives and the rest of it will then
just be grazed
yep i mean he's a farmer from way back
yeah yes yes so he's tidying it up it
will be tidied
he seems it seems a responsible end
would
uh council lamps yeah
um by doing this does that make it um
that
uh for land just about impossible to
sell later on
um to anybody else but if anything
happens on those
that area that block
no i don't believe so it would be
subject to that if we sold the whole
block as one
um as rob just mentioned before if we
did decide to sell
the part of the sliver off to the
adjoining immediate joining owners that
would just come with it
and it could be that if they purchased a
slice of the
of the sliver it could be that that um
that easement gets extinguished anyway
at that point so
what would i only mean the seasons for
either yes
um can you not put a timeline on an
easement in case something changes
in years to come uh you could do but
it's
very unusual that that actually happens
further questions some repeat move
council atkinson
the recommendation someone beat the
second
council brian cather atkinson
yeah look i'm very comfortable with this
happening i mean
everybody's questions around the
untidiness and the piece of land it's
exactly what we set up the committee
that we have
to have a look at uh land disposals or
acquisitions that's
exactly why we're forming a policy and
exactly what we're doing so this
the questions raised will be put and
dealt with
as that policy becomes to fruition this
is a piece of land which requires
something done to it now
and um like most of the stuff we do
around this table when we're in the here
and now we can't do much about it we
either have to
be reactive or proactive this is about
being proactive for a property owner
and we need to get on and do that while
the other committee actually
gets the policy right so we can be
proactive again
in either acquisition or disposal
that's a brian do you wish to speak any
further speakers
counselor stuart yes i'm
really dissatisfied with this and i
can't think of um a
a recommendation or amendment that would
address the fact that
we have an opportunity here to
get rid of what is a ridiculous piece of
a long sliver of land
that has been problematic for a long
time and
bearing in mind that you're going you've
got a deal on the um
on the eastern end of this grounding
this easement is not going to make it
at all any um any
way attractive to the subdivider
to negotiate with the council to take
ownership of that sliver so we're going
to be stuck with it
and asking people
in hindsight to to pay for it
when they've got no need now and the
opportunity to
um remedy a situation where this land
goes into another ownership is going to
be lost in my view forever
so bearing in mind that as i've said i
can't think of
something about well question delegate
delegates chief executive property
manager to negotiate further agreement
to determine the nature and
specification of the fiscal
that doesn't that isn't extensive enough
to
do um to include that sliver of land
because is it question no no
so i i can't think of um in the short
time
a way of including that that
sliver of land and it isn't a straight
bit of land or a flat bit of land it is
like that
and it's full of noxious weeds it will
remain
so we're giving an easement across it
there will be no interest
from the subdivide or joining landowners
to
to come to the party about buying it
so in this instance i just have to vote
against this i think it's an opportunity
unfortunately lost forever
about the fact that if if this was done
a few years ago
perhaps a wider look at it could have
been done but the reserves neck does
constrain us an awful lot
so unfortunately we haven't got the time
because we have to give them an answer
and that's that's fair and it's not fair
to
i mean i would have loved to have gone
to them and said look fifteen thousand
dollars and you can
you can keep it and we've just got to
get through the reserve designation
but that should have been done two years
ago so those sort of opportunities
it would be good to keep an eye out for
them because this is a redundant piece
of land it's a difficult piece
council isn't maintaining it um and it
doesn't actually add any
value to the road so therefore it all
the drainage or anything so
it's actually yeah i take um councillor
stuart's points on this however
you can't do things in hindsight and
you've got to move forward so in this
in this respect the recommendation is
right but i do encourage property and
subdivision team to look at these
opportunities if this makes sense for
the community
let's get on and get it done these sort
of subdivisions take time
we may have the time and it may actually
work out that if they're going to spend
6 000 on these months they might have
spent 15 000 to get the whole piece of
land and make it easy
so i just encourage you to look for that
for future opportunities
thank you any further speakers
right of reply accounts reconciling well
whisper i'd just
really like to reiterate that the policy
we're putting together is for land
disposal or acquisition
it is not about purchase or selling
it is about all of those things it may
be
that that group comes up with the
disposal of this land by the way of
giving it away to the
this property owner we haven't made that
decision yet because the policy hasn't
even come across the stable
so until it does we need to do what it
is necessary to make this
work for the property owner today
looking forward to the future of that
policy either be
acquisition or disposal
okay thank you so we come to the
recommendation now
i put that all those in favor please say
aye country
no see you know so uh so
so says two no's is that right yeah i'll
i'll declare that karen
do you wish your votes recorded just
counsel stewart wishes if i record it
right i think he spoke too soon david
about it being straightforward
all right 8.2 um pages 180 to 186
um budget cons excuse me members
excuse me can we have silence please
thank you
so budget considerations for kaya poor
department right that's
sean
but maybe it's jared
so look the purpose of this report
is to align budget with expenditure
into the current financial year so
we've had a provision of 4 million
overall for park and ride that's been
sitting in the long term plan
uh during this current financial year as
you'll be aware we've been accelerating
the
program of implementing the
[Music]
park and ride following the decision by
the
council as we landed on the final
version of the annual plan
to proceed with this work so look the
um the actual expenditure in
rangiora has largely aligned with what
was within
the budget and this report
requests an additional 24 thousand
dollars be brought
forward into the current financial year
to allow for us to complete the works
we've got in rangiora
um and the more substantial reason for
this report is
recommendation b which is asking for
twenty seven thousand dollars to be
brought forward for
car um so um they
as you'll recall the work in kaiapoi
includes
the car parking facilities under
construction at the moment
uh adjacent to the new world site as
well as
the uh project that we've got
for keeley's to these just to the south
of tram road
so um i i don't think i need to um
go into this in any more detail happy to
take any questions
any questions counts about it followed
by council williams
jerry just looking in the section six
implications and risk financial
implications
it talks about this being within the
overall budget but it doesn't mention
any impact short-term impact on rates
does
are you able to give us any will that
make a difference
for rates going forward
uh yes it will um i can't tell you the
exact figure of the top of my head
so overall it won't um because by the
time
where if by the time we implement all of
the expenditures that's signaled in the
ltp
but when this work is capitalized uh
at the end of the financial year um
there'll be
um an additional
uh there will yeah there will be an
additional just let me
do the numbers quickly in addition about
000 of capital work that we're
capitalizing
and that will have a flow-on effect in
terms of our loan funding
as well as our depreciation of those
assets i i can't just give you an exact
figure off to my head but the answer is
yes it was
supplementary to that could i please ask
that when your staff do something like
this do a pull forward that they please
put that right implication
in the um section six for us yes yeah
and we normally
do that yes we should have done that did
you have something
okay uh castle williams
for the ring you're a side one um
if we took the bike um shelters
or pages out of which are quite
expensive um but that make a difference
because when we originally
were asking about the bike cages we were
basically told that people would be
leaving their expensive bikes here
and um going away on the bus and since
then
i've been to meetings and family at the
buses now i've got the um
the carriers on the front of the buses
and they'll take their expensive bikes
to where they get dropped off at the bus
exchange and then they'll bite to work
so i'm really concerned whether we need
to spend this money
on these expensive cages for these bikes
when they may not be
going to be used would that what sort of
value is we're looking at there
um i suppose yeah had we
uh been aware of this earlier i think
the
shorter answer would have been yes um
and perhaps yeah don young will actually
have an idea
um of whether we've committed but i i
expect we will have committed to the
lion's share of that cost so
i'll be surprised if we haven't um
already ordered the manufacture
of those uh bike cages
so yeah not dawn's nodding so so that
opportunity does not exist um but just
further to
that um question the
bike racks on the front of the bus they
are one
option so some some people do
use those um so but we don't see
each that whether it's a bike rack on
the bus or a cage as being mutually
exclusive
you some customers will be quite happy
to leave their
bike in rangiora and go into town but
other people might need to
you know continue their journey on their
bike when they get off the bus
so this actually gives them a bit some
more options
so overall we think to
deliver the kind of facility that we're
trying to it does give more options for
for people and as i said we're very
committed
to that at this stage anyway okay
um other questions did you hear
yours has answered council board yes
thank you do you like to ask a question
yes
yes i'll see you a signal you'd like to
meet the
recommendation okay we'll just i'll just
check there's any other questions
so you're you're prepared to you're
prepared to move um 8.2
a to j council award seconded by
councillor brian councilwood
thank you um i agree that we need to
keep both options there we need to keep
the bike
um stands available there for people a
lot of people
travel into christchurch and then walk
to work from there and so we need to
have both options available so i'm
very pleased with what's happening and
well
done so it has my full support
council brian i'll just
add my support to the recommendation i'm
really pleased to see
the work that's been completed here and
thank the staff
for all that's been done to bring this
about this is a very important
part of our partnership agreement with
greater christchurch that we have
parkland right in place
as part of the arrangements for the new
northern corridor and some of us
had that opportunity to go and have a
look through along the corridor a few
weeks ago and it's
it's going to be absolutely fantastic
and be a real game changer for our
district but part of that
those discussions was around having park
and ride and express buses in the high
occupancy lane and
i won't traverse that because we've been
over that for some time but the
an important part of that is making sure
that we have parking arrangements there
and for buses to be able to access those
so that that journey will work
well in partnership very um
a lot of excitement around the town
actually i've been picking up from
people who
particularly in kaiapoi are really
pleased to see that there will
also be parking options included there
near the new world
and also informed today that
discussions are progressing well with
the major caravan association
so that's encouraging there's a lot of
excitement about that
potential as well in the town because
they'd like to see it because when motor
caravans association
are there they also bring added
investment
into the district particularly our
restaurants our supermarkets
i think it's something like 140 someone
quoted to me
correct me if i'm wrong but it was
around that sum so that's uh
if that can get over the line it'll be
just fantastic
so um i i'm supportive of the budget and
very thankful to the work
and particularly um i know sean's been
putting a lot of time into it too
i think he's done a really good job of
getting us in a space
that we can make sure that our
commitment is on it
thank you
well i think you've covered most of what
i was going to say really about the
great christchurch partnership it is
an important part of that and
discussions have gone around around that
for
a long time now so so it is a
important piece to the puzzle and i
think that's the biggest thing that we
have to think about this whole
recommendation and what's happening here
is it's peace in the puzzle
and if we're going to get people onto
public transport we have to keep
building
the puzzle until touch time as we fill
it in and
this is a very very important this is
the corner pieces which will help you
fill the center and so
i think i think this is well worthwhile
and maybe we'll sort it
yeah well i will be supporting this i'm
just very disappointed about
words like overspends and um not being
given the full information
originally about these gold-plated bike
stands
at that stage i'd imagine the um
everybody should have been told about
the buses um
do have facilities on take these
expensive bikes into the
works and they carry on because that's
the type of bike
people will be um carrying on further so
just a wee bit disappointed about us not
getting the full information before we
originally
well i originally um were told about
these
bike racks and all that we you know the
other councils i understand
nowhere near as flesh as this um system
and um
i actually wonder whether it was a um a
good spin or not
um and i'm only talking about the bike
racks at this stage
just on what council williams is raising
my understanding and mr palmer you may
be able to help me hear that when he
came to us with the um uh bus routes and
so on they also gave us the details that
the buses
had bike racks on the front of them and
been equipped with those with sometimes
my recollection correct correct it
well my recollection is that there have
been bike racks on the front of buses
for a long time so
i imagine that that is the case yes
i'd just like to say that this i think
that you know this is coming along
nicely it is
as the mayor and deputy mayor have said
um a very important piece to the puzzle
that and what is asked of us of the of
the greater christchurch partnership
um as for there being bike racks and
and whatnot um yes that is something
that that
has always to my knowledge been on buses
but people choose whether or not they
want to use those or put a pram on them
or whatnot so what this does
what we are giving people is as many
options as possible to make it as
as attractive as possible to get them
onto it and by giving them a
comprehensive
range of options whether they they take
their bike they leave their bike there
they you know
which end of their journey one or both
they want to
use a bike this gives people a lot of
latitude to
work out what works best for them which
is all going to be positive
in wooing people onto
using this service so i i say good on
you
carry on gold-plated bike boxes and all
and um yeah hopefully we will we'll see
some good use
some good uptake because i have heard a
lot of people also looking forward to
the service and um the other options
that are going to be open
whenever the northern corridor opens so
well done thank you
miners i just want clarifying with these
bike racks places for is there anywhere
where they can
stand out of the rain you know the
people going on the
shelter a shelter shelter attached with
them
yes there will be a bus shelter at each
of the uh
park and ride sites that we're planning
will be a smallish
shelter but you know just a typical bus
shoulder
we're actually going paper now
are those shelters also as are they
going to be
on top of this price or are they
included in on the price
by this price they are included in the
budget that is presented to you today
they will be
allowed for in that budget they are
separate from the bike
shelters portion of the budget
uh thank you mr mayor i i do have
concerns as to the cost of these
proposals we are looking at a sort of
mode shift of transport to get people to
use
public transport that's
really pressure in my mind coming from
wellington
however i agree that if we don't do it
we'll never know
and i think the concept
is excellent i just hope that people
will use it
and i think it's a matter of um building
it and they will come
well i sincerely hope they do come
otherwise we've
spent quite a lot of money on something
that won't have a lot of use so
i'm i'm optimistic um and
it is one of the cornerstones of
changing people's
ways of getting about and
sometimes called a fossil by my
grandchildren for relying on motor
vehicles
uh this is a big change for me but if we
can get people to use this sort of
system then i'm
certainly supportive of it my only
reservation is the cost
and we we don't know what sort of uptake
they'll be
i think it's really important to know
when we talk about the cost we've
already passed this course
we're as a council together so that
we're not debating the costs today
we're actually debating whether we bring
it forward and so the only
real question is how much impact is it
going to have on rates earlier
than what we expected and which was the
question we were asking
however i'm satisfied that the quantum
we're looking at is not too significant
and it's very very important to get this
project across the line we have a
responsibility
as part of the greater christchurch
partnership we have a responsibility to
our community who are expecting
this type of mode shift to be available
to them so i have
absolutely no hesitation in supporting
it
i'm just very pleased to end and unlike
councillor um redmond
i hope that people will take up this
opportunity
and will use it and then
we'll all know that it's all been worth
one and maybe it will grow very quickly
i'm sure it will
we're running for the head of time which
is good but now i've said that we'll
probably be behind don actually if you
could remain
we'll take your paper now if you like
thanks sean thank you jared
jared you can remain there as well if
you want to don't have to
um so we come tonight 9.2 pages 271 to
tab 12.
so it's flex and radar upgrade so don
thank you thank you mr mayor as the
council will be well aware we've
discussed this
on a number of occasions around this
table and around other tables
and unfortunately due to the timing
of this exercise you'll also note
through the recommendations that this
project is already out for tender
that was a i suppose a calculated risk
that the staff felt comfortable in
taking given that there had been
quite a lot of conversation leading to
this point and we'd also engaged with
the mayor and
the transportation portfolio holder and
the chair of the local community board
before going down this track we also
have the endorsement of the wrangler
advisory community board
i can also pass on now verbally that
aaron has been around
the businesses yesterday and
generally without fail they are
supportive
of the change in direction for
them the cycle way was always a bit more
of an impediment
than a benefit now i know there's
another
group of residents and ratepayers who
will hold
differing views but from the businesses
perspective
they were quite pleased to see it gone
they were concerned about
the impacts that it was then leading to
in trying to
fit it in we have had one
uh of the local businesses
who has expressed quite strong concern
uh about the inclusion of the parking
and has expressed on a number of
occasions that
they didn't wish parking on street
parking to remain
we are drafting a reply to that it
hasn't yet gone but it will be along the
lines of
that it is it is a balancing uh issue
and that while we can understand the you
know the access and the safety
issues raised with regard to the parking
they were counter balanced
both from a staff point of view and also
from a political point of view with the
need
to provide on-street parking to support
the local businesses
so that's just to make sure you have a
full and complete
understanding of the feedback we're
receiving to date
the as i say the work is currently up
attendant will be closing in a week or
two
we're still on track to award before
christmas
and this work should be underway uh
early in the new year
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you any questions of mr
with the increased parking that's being
allowed
hasn't been um has it been a
consideration so that any large trucks
exiting and entering off the road uh
won't be impeded by part cars going in
and out of their
addresses
so just to be clear so everybody's on
the understanding when we say the
increased parking it was increased from
an
earlier proposal but it is still less
than the current parking
so we're not providing more parking than
is down there now we're providing less
but we are providing more than we were
in the earlier versions
of the plan
with regard to the comment you have
raised
there will be no additional parking on
the western side of the road
which is mostly where the large trucks
and the large
big box businesses etc are coming and
going from
uh the exception to that is you will
note in here that
the rangiora ashley community board
has requested that we consider leaving
out a portion
of the curbing at the northern end on
the western side
opposite mcdonald's virtually which
would potentially allow some degree of
usage in that area that
decision has yet to be made we're still
working our way through that
with regard to the eastern side we're
quite comfortable that the parking
restrictions
and the site restrictions have carefully
considered
site and access matters to make sure
those accesses
will be safe to exit and enter
okay any further questions um
i'm happy to move from the chair you're
going to second that
council williams so 9.2 look
firstly say thank you to
fraser who and i've attended a number of
the public meetings that were held on
site
including a meeting um with some
business concerned business owners
i really appreciate the work that both
um fraser and don have done to
consider carefully the concerns that are
raised
we're going to please everyone when we
come to do
works like this but i think the critical
aspect was when the safety audit was
undertaken
there was no way we could achieve all
and the widths that we had on this road
and unless we'd have looked seriously at
piping
which was just going to cost not only
the cost but also
capacity issues along there which is
required in the event if there is
a a stormwater event that was one of the
concerns around
it's just not practical to look at
piping that so we had been able to have
looked at that we had
it was an extra 2.7 million that was a
conservative
estimate to do that work perhaps could
have been able to achieve some of those
things i'm disappointed there won't be a
formed
cycle way down there i really am but um
councilor barnett did ask at the
community board we're sitting there
that alternatives be considered and i
understand staff are doing that and i
think that's a really good suggestion
because i think cycleway linkages are
important in our district
particularly on a piece of road like
this so look forward to seeing what
staff come back with
i also i think it's important that there
is
still car parking this area
notwithstanding that particular
submitters perspective
there are a range of other businesses
that really did want there to be car
parking
and it would really have seriously
impeded their activity and they were
talking about having to leave
if that was the case because
it would have made it difficult for
their particular business activity and
the number had moved there because there
was that ability for parking outside
their businesses and
fast food and other related activities
do need
a drop-off point there so that was
considered
i also support uh car parking remaining
near the
um the mcdonald's area so i hope staff
can accommodate that it is well used now
there's also a bus stop in that location
currently
i think if we were to remove car parking
and stop that it would
potentially affect the use of that bus
stop
there is also a number of businesses
down there that have
high levels of cars
particularly the gym um there's a number
of businesses that don't have quite the
off street parking that
maybe they could uh have on site because
of the size of
um of coverage of buildings that they
have on their particular sites
there is an option down there about
looking at ryan place
as well which is underutilised now
i think would provide some potential
extra capacity if required and that was
a suggestion that came up
from business owners so i hope that we
will look into that but look in general
and i say thanks to both fraser and don
it's been a difficult task
but i think you've landed on the best
outcome that you can within the
constraints that there are so thank you
for the work and
note that it says just mentioned it's
out to tender currently and hopefully we
get a good price
um through that process it's been a long
time waiting to get this
particular area um
to a state that it needs to be because
it's it's it's been in a bed in poor
condition for some time so it's
overdue so look forward to seeing this
project complete
council williams yeah i think it's
a um the best scenario we can end up
with that's good
and i personally are quite pleased we're
not putting a
cycle lane through there mainly because
of the safety reasons but we are going
to look at um
an alternative route there for cycles
but i just
don't personally like cycles and tracks
they don't really mix
so um so i think we're
we're actually covering that by not
having the cycle lane this time but
we will be looking at an alternative
route which
um there's been a couple proposed
nothing far
safer for the cyclists and um and we'll
link the community's
proper but it is a a main access way
into
um ring euro and it's needed to be done
for
yong so the sooner we get it the um the
better it will be so it's called
cancer meetings
yeah this this has been a rather
problematic
problematic stretch of road for for
quite some time and there are a lot of
competing interests for it
um and i think that you've come to as
good
of a solution as possible
notwithstanding the fact that there are
also some
some structural um issues with with what
side of the road we could put it on etc
so you've gotten to a good place
i would like to think that as councillor
williams has just alluded to
that that we will have a cycle
it's a shame that there's not a shared
path but i would like to
see hopefully in the future that we can
work on a cycling path to connect up to
the passenger so that cyclists can
actually have a safe
route through um and into into rengara
in the most direct route because
at present it's quite a big detour if
you want a safe cycling route into
angular from
from the south um but yeah i i take my
head off to you this has been quite some
some journey so um may the force be with
you on your continued journey
um council bound followed by cancer ward
yes i particularly like the comment that
you made don about
trying to fit um a 20-metre carriageway
into 16 meters
so it's a little difficult and so we
certainly understood the juggles
that you've had to do in this area and
we really appreciate the time that it's
taken for you to
bring the community with you and talk
them through the issues that are
actually happening
um just a point though cyclists do have
the right to use the road so
it doesn't matter if there are trucks
everybody has the right to use any road
in our district
and i would still expect there'll be
some cyclists who just cycle quite
happily down that road
and perhaps with the improved
carriageway it'll be a more pleasant
experience for them as well
however there are obviously we had a
submission from people coming from our
commandable area which is actually quite
close that it was
they felt unsafe cycling down that road
in its current state
so a diversion that's more family
friendly
potentially linking with peshendale is
something that we can consider for the
future
but it's imperative we get this project
done people have been asking it
as as councillor melling said for
probably generations actually now
um certainly um it will be
i think we'll be really pleased to see
the result and what
a difference this will make and i think
it may solve some of the issues
that we've already talked about
okay um i just
just a question i'm really thrilled that
this is happening are we
are we starting in january like to start
in january this
this um and and what about tom foonside
road roundabout is that also starting in
january
so is it going to impact very greatly on
traffic
going through there at that time or was
it better to get it all over and done
within one fell swoop
yes it's a very good question and the
staff to give careful consideration to
how these two
projects should work together we ended
up concluding well
if the truth be no and we had a very
tight time frame which it was actually
sort of driving both projects if we
wanted to do them this year
but we did end up considering even with
that that we were probably better off
just biting it all at one time
so the the road disruption will
effectively go from the other side of
the
roundabout all the way through to the
line side road
yes we are a little bit behind the time
frame with regard to the
roundabout it is now intended to go to
tender
about this time next week and uh we
still though have a time
frame for rewarding that before
christmas and again starting that
because of the uh the need for the 10
days it'll probably be later in january
that they get on site there
and the council will recall that they've
delegated authority to award their
contract so we won't be trying to fit in
with a
with a with a council meeting there but
yes there will be quite some disruption
coming through flaxton road for
you know five or six months which is an
unfortunate thing but it is what it is
thank you oh sorry just just adding to
that there will be
two-way traffic through flexton
urbanization as a key part of the
contract conditions so they will be
expected to manage the work
retaining two-way traffic now that of
course may
be disrupted for half a day or whatever
if there's a road crossing or
some specific piece of work but
generally speaking there will be two-way
traffic
at all times on flexton and we're also
pulling together
a similar plan as to how we can
construct the roundabout of flax and
fernside
and retain two-way traffic on that as
well so
that is that is the goal
council brian absolutely a silly
question
the contractors who may be bidding on
the tender that's out now
would know that potentially well that we
were going to go out with the roundabout
that they would know that now
it's actually a very good question and
the answer probably is
not as much as we could have we probably
haven't signaled
the intent for this one to come out
which we could potentially do i could
get that uploaded onto tinder as an
advanced notice
we could do that today that's a very
good for institution
very good suggestion did we did consider
the merits of actually awarding them as
one contract and letting them both catch
up with each other
uh and we ended up not going with that
for a couple of reasons firstly
we're worried about a contractor's
ability to to do each part of it and we
felt giving the whole thing to one
contractor
would just increase that risk and
secondly we felt
the you know the million dollars actual
million and a half dollars ish is a good
size for our good strong local
contractors turning it into a three
million dollar contract
may well price some of our more reliable
and local and trusted contractors
out of that market and so we ended up
keeping them as separate
okay any further speakers
it's all been well said i'm not going to
respond to any of the points because
it's all an agreement really so
which is um which is good so i'll put
the recommendation
a b and c all those in favor please say
aye contrary
to clear that carry thanks don thanks
jared
all right uh if we go back to now 8.3
which is the staff submission to reduce
the impact of plastics on the
environment
like pages 187 to 196.
say so it should be submission pardon me
we remove staff out of the um summary
agenda yes
yeah thank you mom okay
look the purpose of this report today is
um
seeking council's approval of the draft
submission that we've that we've
prepared on behalf of the council
on reducing the impact of plastic on the
environment a very wordy title moving
away from hard to recycle and single
use items discussion document so
um so it was a two phase
consultation um two separate proposals
proposal one is to phase out how to
recycle plastics
and the other is is the um phasing out
of single use items and then the
table on the second on page 188 does
actually show that we're keeping
essentially one twos and fives and
wanting to display
um just uh phase out the rest
um and there's also been the basis for
this has been the the
office of the prime minister's chief
science scientific advisor
from the report in december 2019 so
there's a really strong basis
to make this move and of course we had a
briefing on the
13th of october where i've been the
three of us introduced
these um what was going on here uh
so i think that's i i
assume everyone's able to have a look at
it and look at the submission so i'll
just uh
leave it at that happy to take any
questions
any questions thanks uh casa williams
it may not be relevant for a question
you could answer
me um i noticed in oxford
um this week or might be last week
we had a uh recycling of some of the
farmers
plastics and just this week and places
and all that
and we're accepting plastics that we
can't
recycle on our own transfer station
do you know what the story how we're
going to
get rid of that type of plastic
what story did you know it may not be in
your
grief but it has from as far as i'm
aware there was
about a year ago there was that
procedure process too um
there's a group of six heart too hard to
um whereas i've got a note of it and
somewhere in the report it's
part of the government's program are
ready to start there's a plastic bailing
and packaging like that
agricultural so the recent activity we
had
that was more about hazardous waste and
disposal of some of that plastic rather
than brilliant
recycling initiative overall
it was all going to be recycled it was
all so um
it was a recycling exercise rather than
uh
going to cape valley i just wanted so
it's all going to take value that stuff
not
[Music]
um
council meetings um through you mr chair
perhaps i could address that on paul um
what you're referring to is ag recovery
and
they in amongst many of the things that
they do with that
agricultural plastic is that they i do
believe
um supply the likes of future posts and
whatnot
and they they do they are able to use a
small
amount of recycled plastic
that they collect from farm containers
and and whatnot
into other products but of course they
can't take the entire bulk
of everything that we've got and i and i
think part of it is also just a product
stewardship um thing as well
with regard to like the silage wraps and
things does that sound about right guys
yeah because there's plast back and
there's ag recovery there are two
companies that do
that and um because agricultural
plastics probably
that soft plastic's one of the biggest
problems that we've got particularly in
the rural area
yeah thank you council meetings any
other questions
so moved by council violence seconded by
council meetings
council develop sorry if i snuck in
there quickly council remains um
no this is a really really critical um
submission to make and i think those
questions have been
asked very very well um it
it's really good to see the government
actually putting some focus on this
for it's been talked about for a long
long time
and it's really only going to work with
national directive
and with involving the manufacturers as
well
trying to fix it at the end of end of
line is the ambulance at the bottom of
the cliff and the best thing to do would
be to reduce
the amount of plastic coming into the
work stream so i
thoroughly support the submission i
thoroughly support the work that's being
done
by the ministry for the environment and
i hope the government will also start to
look at some
bigger larger regional recycling schemes
that we can actually get rid of the
waste that we've got
thank you casa meetings
yeah i'm just really just kind of
echoing what kristen said there
i'm really pleased to see central
government stepping up to the plate here
you know they've given us many
directives of
to reduce waste and whatnot and not a
whole lot of tools to do it with
i'm pleased to see them actually moving
in this direction and also
asking councils and businesses to submit
on it
on what we think and i think that our
staff put together a really good
submission to the questions that have
been put to them and
um yeah i tip my hat to you mr o'connell
thank you it's a great report thank you
um i'll just echo the comments that have
been made by
colleagues um already uh and it is a
really important submission i
fully support it so thanks uh mike for
the work that you've done on it out of
interest
i actually popped into the eco central
open day
on saturday and saw the move well it
wasn't operating but saw the resultant
efforts from how the move operates in
there and they had videos in there there
was about a thousand people that
attended
um on saturday which was really
encouraging to see that level of
interest it was a stinking hot day
um and then the in a big open but it was
um and but you do see the downstream
effects of
of what gets in there and what shouldn't
be there um
and if if there's anything government
and that you write counts about it the
leadership does need to come from
central government around product
stewardship
all those other matters that they have
responsibility for so
um certainly hope that the leadership
does
follow through because it will assist us
that we're having to do
a huge amount of work now to re-educate
people on the art of recycling and using
their rubbish correctly i'm not sure
what their current non-compliance and
is but the city were advising me on
saturday that they are still
sitting on 42 non-compliance
um and what's going on in there so it's
a surreal that's
we've been the lockdown period and the
mixed messaging that happened through
that period has set us back light years
it's costing us a lot of money and and i
don't need to
tell you all the work that we've been
doing on letters through
the solemn hazardous waste working party
bin audits and the education that needs
to follow so
there's been quite a bit of effort in
this space but general
going to government and getting some
better tools and for them to take a lead
in this space will certainly
be of of great assistance so thanks mike
really support you recommend your um
submission counselor edmund followed by
council duty
thank you mr mia i'd like to support the
submission also
um i think the key thing is that we're
not doing away with all plastic
um modern society relies very strongly
on plastics
and i was looking around this room we've
got plastic lights
plastic cover on the projector
there's plastic in the laptop and the
speaker system
there's plastic everywhere plastic pen
council williams
but it's a matter of redirecting the
plastics
the common ones the disposable ones
to the type which can actually be
recycled or repurposed
um the light fittings my sons are
plumber
and pvc pipes
they could go back to earth and wear
pipes i suppose if you do away with
those but
i think they're not something that are
disposed
of on a regular basis so i think it is
good that the government is taking the
lead because when i buy a product in a
plastic bottle
i generally may not have a choice
whether it's a disposable bottle or not
i would like to think that whenever i
purchase something in a plastic
bottle for example that it will be
recyclable
and local this the retailer really
doesn't have a lot of control it's the
manufacturer
so i see this is a step in the right
direction and
who knows we may bring back glass milk
bottles
council redmond council duty
just this all about this plastic and
and recycling things takes me right back
to the 2001 zone five and six where this
was first brought up
um and and uh trying kathy keys tried
very hard to get that
to go forward but it's like everything
it's words and
not too much uptake unfortunately but it
has to
it we've got to seriously look at it now
we needed to seriously look at it back
way back then but the government of the
day wasn't very interested
further speakers casabana wrote a reply
just a couple of points i pick up from
the debate um
really would like to dispel that urban
myth that council
plastic is is being recycled if it's
clean and the correct type
um and council ruben's quite right but
we do have some
responsibility as a consumer and so i i
go around and tell everybody the mantra
only by
one two and five easy to remember if
it's not one two and five don't buy it
if you could possibly avoid it um and
that the other thing is councillor dirty
mentioned the fact that hasn't been done
since 2001 it's
talked about for a very long time
there's a huge cost
and the problem is who is going to pay
and that's the question that still
hasn't been answered
okay oh thank you councilman
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that caring thanks
mike
so we now come to item 8.4
um vanessa thompson pages 197-255
thank you good afternoon everyone the
purpose of the
report today is to seek your feedback on
the draft why mccary
draft visitor marketing strategy i
should say um
so the draft is still subject to tweaks
from staff enterprise north canterbury
and the tourism consultant
as well as your feedback today minor
tweaks it's important to know there's no
additional funding request that we're
asking of council to support this draft
over the next or the full strategy
over the next five years
we've updated the name to visit a market
marketing strategy rather than visit a
strategy
just to try and contain the scope of it
so we've got limited resources in the
next five years between
enterprise north canterbury and council
so we felt that renaming it
and making it more streamlined sort of
supports that contained scope
and that's probably the main things from
me so i'm happy to take any questions at
the stage
thank you any questions okay we
oh sorry councilman i guess the big
question
vanessa is how are you going to
implement this strategy with the very
small budget that we currently have
so it's based on the existing budget
that emc already gets for promotions and
it'll be up to them primarily to decide
how they distribute that within their
activity
we've contained the actions accordingly
so the tourism consultant was well aware
that the budget wasn't going to increase
and work with enc to contain those
actions around promotions
so that's probably the main response
around that
okay counselor
thank you thanks very much for this um
i'm just
wondering with the when you when trying
to do the marketing
um whether you would be looking at what
uh marlboro did with the
package that came out for everybody the
sites and places to
to go actually i'm not aware of that
it's something i probably need to
investigate yeah we can certainly look
into it yeah
it came out last week okay
okay councillor edmund uh just a
correction i think vanessa on page two
three three of diligent uh it refers to
a council representative andrew allen
from the wooden theft and community
board i
thought it might be andrea thank you
spotter
council becky you're picking up from
from wendy's comments about
um it's not our job to tell them how to
do it but i've noticed in the
in the print media in the last month um
magazines like metropol
and avenues hironui and selwyn have been
massively come and visit our you know
did you see that cell when said they've
got three waterfalls who knew come and
see our waterfalls
nothing from wimac can you just take
that on board i mean we don't tell them
how to do their job but
and maybe there isn't enough budget to
do it but i i see there's
there's been a dearth of stuff from us
everyone else from kaikoura to
wherever is pouring it in there yeah
just just on that actually if i can just
add a comment we're looking at doing
themed maps which is a new um
option for us in the next five years and
that'll be working with the tourism
advisory group
which will include some stakeholder
representatives and that'll be um
looking at the district what have we got
to offer so we might do
you know a whole themed map around
boutique shopping in the district and
then promote that heavily out
externally there might be all the walks
in the district it's just putting those
experiences into groupings
so that you sort of create that that
reason for people to come and visit
basically
i don't i don't think we've done that in
the past it's sort of been quite
independent how we approach that
so this is a much more targeted focused
way of doing it in the future
and our tourism consultant has certainly
seen other towns overseas and australia
do that approach and actually get quite
a bit of promotion around that
simon with your indulgence mr mia um
whilst it's not in the recommendations
uh we've been through an iterative
process with the stakeholder group and
and various other groups for uh refining
this plan
noting that it is very much an
operational plan for enc and council to
implement a series of says
as discussed just there uh would be
interested in the council's view on
whether this needs to uh come back for a
formal adoption for council where the
council
through this process is happy for us to
now go away
and finalize and make any final
changes such as names through the
management team
or accounting to implementation working
group and then finalize the document and
implement it through that
through that fashion so you're saying
simon you don't think we need if
which is noting the final version of the
strategy will come
back to the council meeting on the 1st
of december yes that's right
with the council's indulgence we're more
than happy to bring it back in december
but we
we're not hearing through this process
or any other form of process
that the document needs to substantially
change it's been
the draft has been through a number of
iterations and we thought it might be
one way of just saving council a little
bit of time we can just
move this on and and adopt it in a
different form
counselor thank you um i just feel in
the
these circumstances at the moment that
we need to to move a bit quicker
because we have got communities and
we've got businesses in our whole
area that really need a shot of steam
so to say and i just think um
we everyone is hopping on this marketing
room we're coming up to christmas
holiday time it is time that we
sold our area and um and made it
well we would like to come here you've
got so many different things
for people to look at you know you've
got your holiday parks and
ashy gorge with all that attraction and
the towns are all booming and buzzing
and i think it's an ideal time
to promote
cancer meetings
hello guys i did read through your
strategy it's quite fascinating what
you've come up with
it's good to see you kind of thinking
about consolidating our offering
because as we've all seen over over the
years
for instance hironu has got their alpine
pacific triangle concept
we could have a kyoto kitai kind of
concept because we have mountains we
have rivers we have oceans and
everything
in between um interestingly
yesterday while i was flicking through
catching up on facebook
an ad popped up for houdini
to explore the alpine pacific triangle
it's here
it's lovely in it and it's a it's a 450
per person dollar per person
offering basically giving giving a whole
range of options available on um on that
triangle
something at hernia or sorry in hamner
something in kaikota
something in waipara and and we can do
that too
i like your concept of your um the road
trips
and i i do think too that we need to
think more on that sort of um
adventure stuff i didn't see a whole lot
of mention of mountain biking in there
which
there's some outstanding mountain biking
trails that we have
and a lot of the other things were
mentioned but
but um yeah it'll be interesting to see
what you come up with i won't rehash
everything you put in there but
but um yeah i think you're off to a good
start but yeah um
i don't think there was a question in
there my question
my question is that yeah can we perhaps
maybe
cash in on some of some hopefully
organic
facebook marketing once we get our
concepts consolidated
and and get that out there we can
certainly pass that feedback on to enc
it's just important to note that enc
will be delivering a lot of the
promotion so our area of focus is around
infrastructure
enhancements um influencing partners but
primarily the marketing side of that
wall sit with enc
but we can certainly look at the
facebook marketing i think that's
something they're going to be
all over as well as part of their
promotional stuff
and our comms team have kindly um said
they they will support where we can
as well thank you councillor edmund
did you have no so the um
under if uh perhaps a suggested way
forward might be
um adopts the waimakariri visitor
marketing
strategy comma 2025
uh noting minor changes will be made
prior to publication something along
those lines
well that how does that sound
that that would be perfect thank you mr
mayor okay
yeah so me councillor atkinson secretary
council award
council reckons it well the strategy is
a good way forward it's um
there's a lot of stuff in here that's
already being done i mean we can all
pick on
different ways of how we should be
marketing and how we shouldn't
um i mean people are right if you i get
a sunday paper
on sundays and then there is a an escape
version
i'm not sure how you're supposed to
escape new zealand but however it is an
escape version
and um and and there are there are
people there are travel agents out there
at the moment visiting parts of their
own country
um i could put forward that we should be
asking those particular people to come
and visit our country and do the writer
get part of the country and do the
write-up but i mean we can have all of
those
i mean i've been involved in enc since
its
inception with this council and it's
done a very good job on marketing
it's picked the trends and speaking of
trends is the perfect one
um some years they go to trends some is
they don't go to trends because it fits
with their market and other years it
doesn't
so these guys are experts we ask them to
do a job this is a strategy we're asking
them to stick by
so i think it's a very good way forward
for them to make the decisions on our
behalf
and for us to trust them to do so
thank you councilwood thank you
um i just want to acknowledge all the
work that's been
undertaken in the last three four months
you've both been very busy we've had
some great workshops
and i think it's set the foundation and
with the consultant that we've had we've
had
some very good discussions and i think
that now we've got the base
to to move forward um and i think it
must be mentioned that you know
enterprise north carolina are a great
tool
for us because they're independent and
they're able to facilitate
and get a lot more funding that we
are able to give them so that we can
maximize the people on the ground to
do the work for us and so i really take
my hat off to heather and her team
they really add value to um to to the
marketing strategy for our district
so i'm very happy to support this and
i know that the groundwork's been done
we've worked very hard in the last few
months so now we can put it all into
into practice thank you
yes it was a pleasure to be involved in
this project it was very well run
um i felt like the whole room was taken
into consideration
and the thoughts of the whole group have
been encapsulated in the strategy
very well which is can be very difficult
to do with a diverse audience
and this strategy for me i've been
through a few of these too and
this is quite different this is actually
quite a change from what we've had
previously
many of the elements that we deliver
will be the same but they're directed to
a completely different market
and that's where it's going to be
different we have to direct to new
zealanders
and the our market is still friends and
family
but as you say we've got a lot of
competition out there i know that um
there's an awful lot of camper vans i've
been on a couple of trips recently
they're just camper vans for miles and
that's a completely different market
that we have to market to
um from our friends and family who come
across the bridge from christchurch
and i also note um recently my father
did a road trip
from georgie in his mobile house
that he has and um he mentions going
from kaikoura to mile brit nelson
what about us dad you know we're
somewhere in the middle but i get the
feeling that we also need not only the
adventure activities but we've really
got to focus for seniors because the
seniors have the money
they spend the most money in our
district and they're out there traveling
um and just to comment on the facebook
the most facebook is valuable
if everybody shares it so the main thing
is you can put as many posts out there
as you like
but it's up to us to share it with all
our friends our family
everyone that we know and that's how you
get great organic reach through facebook
which is also a lot cheaper
uh just briefly i i agree the comments
have been made
i think the visitor marketing strategy
was well overdue thank you for
um vanessa and simon for getting this uh
i guess before us really and then to a
forum and i i was impressed at
the time i had available to come along
uh the level of engagement and the new
sort of people that were sitting there
that hadn't previously engaged and
um moteliers and and other people who
were represented there
i was really interested that the new
market for us actually is
auckland they're our new australia um
effectively and they're the people that
are coming down here to visit
so it is rethinking council violence
exactly right and other comments around
motorhomes
people are now getting out and
experiencing
our country which is a great thing
really so there is an opportunity
i note the comments to be made about
enterprise north canterbury that
i think personally they're doing an
excellent job and use this scope to
always do change but they are looking at
that all the time and around food is one
area that they're looking at at the
moment and around i forget the exact
type there is a term
food there's a there's a term that's
been developed and trademarked at the
moment
which is to look at the opportunity that
we
have here and not only here in our
district but in north canterbury so
they are looking to be a lot more
creative in that space and to look at
opportunities that may exist
for us and to take us into new and to
new markets
recognising that we do have some of the
best food producers
and wine in new zealand within our
region so
thanks for the work you've done i think
it's really good and
uh i certainly support it
further speakers council reconciliation
might rather reply
just to say that it is overdue this um
2015 was the last one
that we did and we did did get it done
i think rather new markets these are
very much
old markets that we now need to focus on
thank you covert
they've always been there and it's
always been a part of our district that
uh we have tried and tried and tried to
make sure that we capitalize on
unfortunately international travel got
in the way of that many times because
there was a percentage of people who
went through here
and particularly with their own
retailers i.e the um
the moteliers and so on were busy out
chasing we won't call it the big buck
but because it's the same buck but they
were chasing the international one as
opposed to the local one
i think this is going to give us a
chance to focus on local and if we can
get that right in this district
we can put in some tools and one of
those is motorhome association
i do note that on monday they handed out
their hundred thousandths
gold ticket or golden wings to their
uh to their hundred thousandth member so
that is a massive amount of caravans and
camper vans that are
certainly on the road and just belong to
one organisation
so if our district can concentrate on
the tools
to get that which is where i believe the
strategies is heading by doing the local
thing we can get those tools set up
hopefully by the time we get a bit of
international travel and things are
starting to happen again
we may be able to shift into that but
what will happen is we have the basic
right
thank you uh so with that i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say
contrary to clear that carry thanks
simon vanessa
okay uh now come to item 8.5
so it's pages 256 to 261.
sarah's not here today but i i think i
probably cover this
unless you want to mr palmer um
so uh this is just around
uh council portfolio amendments
so uh as i indicated at the start of the
two
at start of the council term i was keen
to
see how things were going 12 months on
and so thank you all for
being part of sort of a review really
and
as a part it's part of that it was good
to hear how
um everything was travelling um and any
uh advice sorry any changes that you
would like to have seen in your
portfolios
some i've been able to make help in
others
it's a bit more difficult around
committee structures so
there wasn't many chat as you'll have
seen here there's not many changes i've
proposed
and some of them i just couldn't we
weren't able to achieve easily within
making sure that the numbers work for
you on on respective committees but
you'll see in the recommendations where
just by agreement um council duty
and council award are just going to
switch
there and also
given her just around the with district
plan load as well with
communication customer service portfolio
slight change there
with council atkinson picking up the
communications portfolio it's also
recognising that
council atkinson's role around
international relationships isn't as
um
due to uh external issues uh that's
being
um uh there's not as much going on in
that portfolio and saying that though
um patient now and
there is work going on in that
particular committee so
um and the other was just also
recognizing with councillor blacky the
regeneration portfolio kind of winding
down
in some aspects was to look at a slight
change there now
um despite what if says i'm going to
suggest something different
because it didn't read how i would have
liked that um
so we're looking at um
if would read approves a new portfolio
land-based indigenous
reserves um including in brackets
including river margins and taking our
ecan
and that so it's it's recognising that
that's an area uh council black is
currently
uh working in i know there's a little
bit of crossover with
myself and counselor steward and we'll
work that um
how that exactly works out but there's
uh in the council stuart does have quite
a high um load in her portfolio too so
it's a bit of balancing there so
there's no other changes proposed
because i think uh actually by and large
everything's working really well i
i in the meetings i had with each of you
there was no
concerns raised with me and i've tried
where i can to be able to make those
changes that keeps everything
um balanced all right any questions
did you wish to quit a question
counselor worms
oh you're going to move uh see
sorry what's that sorry
so it's a new title of new portfolio of
land-based
indigenous reserves including river
margins
so he's not going to be native and
indigenous
reserves reserves
it's just including river margins
so i'm sorry i i didn't see this as as
fully as i should have done beforehand
so
my apologies for that so it wasn't how
it was intended to be worth it but
anyway we've we've i think we've
clarified that sufficiently
any further questions council williams
you're prepared to move
seconded by council redmond do you wish
to speak to it
council redland any further speakers
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye contrary to clear that carry
alright so we're now moved to item 10
10.1 health and safety report mr palmer
thank you mr mia a monthly report
no significant injuries or accidents
that i think you should
be concerned about just noted that the
accommodation project
is progressing well staff are coping
with that
well and uh being quite accommodating
and supportive the stage one which is
upstairs and
the service center
our hope is that by the week before
christmas that
uh that work will be completed and um
that will enable start stage two to
occur which is
putting everybody a lot of people back
in upstairs
and then uh working on the downstairs
which we'll see
our service center uh front counter
shift down to in front of the current
chambers and a lot of the staff that
were in there
will be in the chamber so they'll be
continuing
uh musical chairs going on
for the coming months but there are no
other matters within this report that i
think i need to draw your attention to
as always happy to answer any questions
thank you mr palmer questions
counselor um
i've noticed that a few staffs actually
seem to be actually loving their new
accommodations and may not want to go
back
to where they were how are we going to
manage that
in terms of some of the accommodations
in the building are
we've known their limitations for some
time and the fact that they're now in
quite nice accommodations carefully i
think is the answer
you're right uh it's improving their
mental morale
there are there are some who are
certainly benefiting from some
better spaces than we've had over the
last
months and years that is true
i'm confident that the
refurbished spaces will be equally as
nice if not
better than what they're temporarily
occupying
you'll be aware that
uh it related teams who are now in
durham street that's a
i'll call it a semi-permanent relocation
so so that does uh has created the
additional
space that will then
allow people i won't say to spread out
because people will spread out
to the space that's available but it
will provide some opportunity
for further growth and for that to be
all accommodated but
i am pleased with the temporary
accommodation and the way
uh staff are dealing with probably the
biggest issue we have
is meeting room availability
and um and the uh find that
finding that you don't look at your
diary close enough and that's me
confessing
turning up in the wrong space and uh
there's nobody else here why is that
and then
the way people are responding is really
good and
hopefully we create some new work
environments that they find equally
appealing once they're back home again
and yeah it was a it was a similar
experience to what happened in the late
90s
the council staff got scattered to the
four winds
and those who went into new
into their temporary accommodation they
developed their own
particular culture which is can be a
good thing
but actually can make them a little bit
more insulated
as well so it's got advantages and
disadvantages but
he is very conscious of that issue
you've raised just a second question
also
um there's been some issues with i.t
connectivity in some of the different
locations
it has even a plan established to make
sure that there is good
i.t connectivity and all the meeting
spaces and all the areas
that councillors also have to attend
places
so they can actually access the internet
so that's about wi-fi connectivity
predominantly for visitors into spaces
and
uh you note that and even in this
notably durham street and pegasus
community center
we encountered but we have problems
durham street that's interesting um
they've got really good they've got
really good uh fiber cable in there they
probably haven't thought about visiting
not sure you can't connect over there
on our computers
me so it's all my fault again but you
have trouble too
so it's just if we think to meeting
spaces we do need a basic level of
connectivity for
our gadgets generally
just wondering if that could just be
looked at to make sure it is working
properly
i'll take a note of that just for
frustration it's my
mental well-being okay
any other questions of the philip
sorry that's redmond
[Laughter]
oh very good excellent
all right so um no further questions i'm
gonna prepare to move
the report made by nikki uh council of
meetings seconded by
councillor redmond yes mailings
nice to see that we haven't had any
accidents of note
and that things are progressing well
with the refurb and hopefully we can
lure them back to their new
accommodations someday
thanks councilman guest ridland
uh the only comment would be that the
injuries appear to be of a very minor
nature
a couple of near-misses one in the
council chambers i notice
um and somebody uh falling down the
stairwell at the back of farmers so
that's something we must keep an eye out
for um but no it's
good report and they don't appear to be
any issues
if you're the speakers
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye contrary to clear that carried
i need to just go back to 9.1 pages 262
um to 270. thank you for the reminder
adrian
okay so we've got a report here
uh who's going to speak to that it's
from nick
so through it
do you happy to speak to that jim should
we just it's just a report back it's
been fairly well
discussed is there any is there any
questions on the report
so there's a recommendation you prepared
to me sorry any questions firstly
moved councillor blacky secretary
councillor duty any for any discussion
gets to view the discussion yes
counts about
can you sorry sorry i'm just trying to
i'm trying to catch up with mia's
fast-tracking this report i'm not trying
to fast track it at all i was just
um so fit speaking to its fire i was
just trying to keep speed up with our
nation we've got a lot to get through
so thank you um i would really like to
ask this committee
to please vote no and i just want to i
want you to hear me out as to why
just keeping your minds completely open
okay
it's no reflection i really believe we
should be voting no to adopting this
bylaw
and it's absolutely no reflection on the
initiators
of and the intention of what they tried
to do
they had concern from resilience they
raised an issue
they discussed it with staff they
investigated all of that is absolutely
fine
they then took it to a panel which is
taking it to the communal community
and the panel tried really really hard
to work through the issues
the panel wasn't unanimous so it shows
that there were concerns
over this bylaw it was really tricky and
the submitters
weren't actually submitting on what we
were adopting today they submitted on
noise
they submitted um what else was their
rubbish
compost they submitted on hoardings and
other
caravans and other nuisance factors that
they don't like seeing in their
neighborhood
which is absolutely fine and it's their
right to submit but the final we're
trying to adopt today or looking at
adopting today is about
long grass right and we didn't actually
get any submissions on that we've had
some concerns but we didn't get
really hardly any submissions it was on
general nuisance
when regulations consider requests from
someone when they consider
a complaint the first thing that the
regulations committee do
is they look at what legislation can
back them up because the local
government act gives us no power
to actually enforce anything it gives us
no power
to recover cost it gives us no power
to actually follow up
any sort of enforcement except through
the courts
which we generally don't do because it's
incredibly expensive and i
can't see us following up a complaint
about long grass
through the courts what happens now
we get a complaint from a rate payer
they come to regulations
they already deal with them they talk
them through and they say this
at the moment all we can do is give you
the address of the person
and they can write them a letter and i
noted on facebook yesterday someone had
done that
in pegasus they had got the letter of
the absentee
owner of the section they lived in
singapore
they wrote them a letter in singapore a
nice letter asking
if they could maintain their section the
leader came back from them saying
apologizing
for not maintaining this section and
they have maintained it ever since
that's how it's supposed to work that's
how civil relations are supposed to work
the definition of is really really hard
it's hard in a court of law it's okay
for one person may not be okay for
someone else
what we are doing with this bylaw is we
are putting staff in the middle
of this civil issue
we are putting staff and costing time
costing money and we're also giving the
putting them as the barrier between two
neighbours
we're actually putting staff in a
situation of neighbour wars
which is really difficult it's not a
tool
in their toolbox it's giving them extra
acrimonious work and
it's not necessary it really sets a
dangerous precedent
we are using bylaw mechanism
to tackle a community issue
we have to give the message to our
community council cannot fix every
issue that upsets our community we try
and we can lobby
and we can advocate but we can't fix
every issue that everyone brings to us
we all know this
this one is a covenant issue so we need
to encourage our community to find civil
solutions
we need to encourage them but if they
have a neighbour dispute over
property that's not maintained it needs
to be handled with their neighbor
if that doesn't work and there's some
problems that's when they go to their
lawyer
or if there's real acumen it escalates
to the police
it's a civil dispute it's not a council
dispute
i'm asking you today please don't take
the campus council down that path
please don't ask our staff to be
involved in civil disputes
causing them more grief than what we
currently face
when we just have to give them an
address
i ask you to save costs and staff time
on what is the subjective issue that's
going to be very hard to define in a
court of law
we talked in the bible we talked about
the manner appropriate to the area
and to encourage responsible love
management of property
we don't have to have a bylaw to
encourage
responsible management of property so
i'm asking you today
do not put stuff in that position not
put this council in this position
and to vote no to adopting this filing
thank you
thank you i'd like to speak to it now um
here's the initiator of the bylaw along
with um
council williams um the reason this came
about in the first place was because of
complaints that we received around
originally around long grass when
and and there were situations and there
are situations where there are neighbors
against neighbours and and
no two ways about it if if if they were
taking care of these sections absentee
landlords
or owners it wouldn't have been an issue
but in this instance
that's where it was happening both here
in rangiora instances in kaiapoi
and also instances in pegasus and so
we did through i worked with um because
i was chair of dpnr at the time and i
worked with
mr harrison and we found that rather
than reinventing the wheel there was a
nuisance by law that the auckland
council had developed so we
looked at that and the provisions of
that made some changes and it was
brought forward to the council for its
consideration
council decided it would go out and
consult which it did
i went around to each of the community
boards who all supported
uh having this bylaw also went
uh and talked to a number of community
organizations who
also were in support of it it was
originally to be just for long grass it
got extended
when it went to our staff who who also
were
was supportive of seeing a bylaw
developed but they added a whole there
was a whole raft of things that raided
in there
so in the end um i think the the what
what ended up happening with the
panel was right that it was confined to
just long grass because effectively that
has been the main issue
it's right um other organizations should
be dealing with this
um for instance that's where the change
happened i think it was an unintended
consequence of the law
that meant that the con the the ability
for our council was removed
um to respond to these matters when it
transferred defends
finns have no interest unless there's a
direct fire risk
in this instance um in in council by
that's right you know
we don't really want to have bylaws in
place where we don't need them
don't really necessarily i think
government don't want to put laws in
place as well where they don't need to
but unfortunately there are instances
where people
need a bit of a stick um in terms of um
or there needs to be something in the
toolbox
and which our staff can then use uh to
hopefully discourage uh behaviours and
there are a number of community
number of people in the community
waiting for this by law to come about
my understanding from discussion with
our staff is that they are supportive
of uh having this bylaw here i haven't
heard
anything to the country in that regard
i'm not seeing
that hopefully that we would have to
recover costs through the courts if we
didn't have to hopefully common sense
would prevail but the test is there if
we even need to
that we could take that step my personal
view is that i'd hope that we wouldn't
revert to using the courts but that's
the only mechanism
that we have in place in which to really
test it if we have to
i would hope it's in the toolbox as a
way of discouraging
behaviours and and ideally people take
care of their sections if you own a
section you should be taking care of it
unfortunately that doesn't occur and
there are a number of instances where
we have to we get involved because
people see us as the last cab off the
rack
um so i i would ask that you do support
this it's been through a proper process
it's had a hearing panel
they've gone through it it's had two two
goes at it now
uh and i think where it's got to is in
best shape it can be and i think the
work of the hearing panel that they've
done
it's here before you today um and i'd
ask you to adopt it
further speakers council reckinson
fathered by councilman one of the
questions councilman said it's a matter
of
covenants it's not my understanding that
kaipur and rangira have any gov
covenants over any normal section
would end all of those places pegasus
may do for a short period of time until
the owners are gone
am i correct in that assumption that if
places don't have covenant
then how can it be a matter of covenant
i can't answer that question
i think um it's on
covenants usually have an expiry period
for most of the urban areas like in
rangiora and kaiapoi they would be
expired
noting that the bylaw relates to
undeveloped it's not actually
sections that are already built on so
it's undeveloped section so
um some of the others do have covenants
whether
on i can't answer whether they
have covenants around the length of
grass what
prior to building a dwelling on those
houses
on those sections i don't know um
so theoretically it could be covered
you know covenants can cover a very wide
range of things on
uh sections so it's
feasible i imagine to have a covenant
for i don't know whether they're
actually in place or not
did you wish to speak
okay councillor williams
i actually don't think it's all about
neighbours sometimes i've um
up in melbourne for example i'm driving
past the section there and saw grass and
all that there
i get them annoyed about um
[Music]
other areas that are growing in um
areas so and what i'm trying to get at
because i'm getting a nasty
funny look from me colleague uh excuse
me that's not necessary no
i know it's not necessary i shouldn't
get a funny look no no hold on we're not
going to get into this
please just confine your comments of
debate councilman yep
cool but what i'm getting at is
there's areas in there and they are
districts not um
classes neighbors are having an effect
from it everybody has an effect because
um they've got
awards for beautiful towns and all that
drama coming around and all that drama
if we get lip sections get out of hand
and some of them do it affects the whole
of the community
um i think we also should um think about
staff as mentioned about enforcement of
the projects
so i think i understand we employ staff
particularly for
enforcement so that's their part of
their jobs and their description
um and if it had to go to a
court scenario we need to start getting
bit modern and
don't have to start involving big
expensive lawyers and solicitors and
what have you
and it's probably time after something
here to um set an example we need to
think about this small claims court
situation which is
a minimal cost to get a a major problem
sort of there
so that's it thanks council williams
council steward thank you mr mayor um
i share a lot of the concerns that my
colleague council obama has raised about
this bylaw
and having sat on the panel they're even
more pertinent
as the person who heard all the
arguments for and against
i'm relatively comfortable with
where it's ended up in that we've
eliminated all the um
all the um nuisances that were brought
to us
in that they are covered essentially by
every every other
piece of law that local government can
can enact and there is
seemingly the long grass remains
um as one that should have been picked
up by fans perhaps that isn't
so i am persuaded to
vote for it bearing in mind that
on july the 31st 2021 which is about
um eight months down the track we have
an
effectiveness review and i
am very keen to see a report on that
in eight months time and that will
i think and should do for everybody else
around this table
trigger whether in fact after we look at
the effectiveness
review whether the whole bylaw should be
reviewed and that is 8.2 this by-law can
be reviewed at any other time
before the date of 2025 when it comes up
for a five-year
at the discretion of the council and i
am
going to be watching that because i do
agree that
we we've ended up as in fact a community
program
a community problem and that
you know some people don't like the look
of grass there
in the urban area and fair enough but
i do want to see that after all this
effort that this is an effective way of
dealing with this
and if it isn't then in fact um
as when i sat down the on the panel
i would like to think that we have
enough um
uh community care within our our
towns that if there is a is a problem
seen by a group of people that in fact
they can volunteer to approach the
neighbor and or the person and say
let's get together and mow your loom
or whatever so i'm very keen to see
the eight months trial and i consider it
a trial
and that we have some really serious
consideration then
about whether this is the mechanism
that's going to do the job for us
so thank you okay further speakers count
threatened uh thank you mr mayor
property maintenance by law is not a
wide-ranging amenity by law
it's very specific uh it relates to long
grass
and in my mind uh the fire risk
that long grass can uh cause
in the community
weather 200 centimeters which i
understand is the length of one of these
is the appropriate measure or not well
the jury's out on that one
but it is a start and i i think it will
be
very infrequently used in fact i would
be surprised if in the next eight months
it's probable
so we'll find that out when the review
comes along
as the portfolio holder for regulation
no staff members have said to me they
have any concerns about their safety
or implementation of a by-law so
whilst i do hear what council of barnet
and councillor stewart is saying
i'm prepared to give the spy laura a
fear for you go
thank you you're the speakers
casa becky do you wish to excite your
brother reply because
it's been covered well in the last 10
minutes yes it's it's
it's been reduced down to a
long long grass bylaw and that was
deliberate because as has been explained
to you
everything else that we took out is
covered by other statutes and other
regulations
yes it's not it's it's it's not perfect
by any means but the comment was made
that um this is a community issue and it
isn't the staff's job to fix community
issues it actually is
at the end of the day because you're
dealing with unreasonable people if we
had a society of reasonable people
we wouldn't need this at all and then we
conflict either
but we do and we have and so you need
something and yes the bylaws
as we all know have got no teeth and
that's good coming from a dentist
but and we see that all the time at
pegasus where
the hoons are ripping up our sand dunes
and their buggies
and and we can't do it very we can do
very little about it
because it's the same thing that's a
separate issue the fact that the fact
that we cannot
have have a fine system backing the
bylaw is a totally separate issue
so yep we go with this in the meantime
give it a try run and see what happens
okay thank you council becky i'll put
the recommendation all those in favor of
the country
and declare that carried okay and
counsel
which i recorded okay so i'm just gonna
walk through these minutes
and uh and then we'll break for
afternoon tea
so um first we've got
item eleven eleven point one to eleven
point six
uh moved by council thank you second
oh sorry yes
youth council on page 307 it says
um that i was to set up a um
sustainability working group which was
news to me and probably news to nikki
that correction um yes but
it's just we'll just note that
correction um but thank you
so um you're prepared to move uh council
blocking 11.1 trillion point
six seconded by council award um
any discussion all those in favor sorry
i was going to take all the minutes and
one yep so did you have a question
oh that's the next one sorry yeah
yes on page 312
of that youth council thing as well is
uh
the um on page 312 it's the
25th of august because we don't get
these minutes
um it just says nikki millings expressed
concern around the spasmodic wi-fi
connections in some rural areas
broadband wi-fi and broadband are two
different things
that's a matter we should take up at the
next youth council meeting but if you
could know
other than that yeah um but yeah i was
gonna otherwise um
thank you very much al for giving me my
um my group back thanks
adrian if we could just note that uh and
yeah so with those corrections that's
moved
with those corrections it's made any
other corrections moved in second
sorry not corrections but noting of what
the corrections might be for those
committees to address
um items eleven point one twenty eleven
point six moved and seconded
all those in fact i'll put that all
those in favor please say i
can't try to clear that carriage item 12
community board minutes for information
um did you have a question councilman
page 344 of the clairport to a hilly
community board
i'm noting the report about the ohoka
road island road intersection
i wanted to ask mr palmer if a report
could be brought to
utilities and roading about the traffic
numbers
and accidents happening at that
intersection and also
perhaps an update on you seem to have
had a lot of recent pressures in the
district
um i just wonder when that next report
on crashes
is going to be brought because this has
been raised the councilor level as well
as that board level
so i see i see the reports was
circulated to the committee for
information
um
i don't recollect what the report
includes but i
you know and circulating circulating any
updated data any data we have
is not not a problem if
providing we've got access to it it was
kind of asking hoping that we could get
a report brought to you
because i believe that this is a
significant
why don't we why don't we just we can
request that
it done
[Music]
portfolio holders councillor williams
and myself we had a discussion
with mr cleary and with joanne the other
day
and one of those measures was this
particular intersection so it will be
coming up
um as part of consideration the writing
program
because it's been it has been identified
by my number is concerned
yeah okay but i it is coming it is going
to be coming up as part of our
consideration of ltp
all right any other points so there's
any other questions so there's a
recommendation
moved by council atkinson secretary
councillor barnett
any discussion always in favor i can't
try to clear that carriage
we deal with 13.1 which is just
recommendation the information be
received
someone appeared to move that council
duty
yeah i knew you were yep um
and seconded by council awards any
discussion
always in favor aye contrary to clear
that carriage
so um uh no correspondence
um item 15.1 is my diary
see any questions move to council
barnett seconded by cancer duty any
discussion
i'll put that all those in favor i can't
try to clear that carriage
i think at this point we just well
how are you feeling should we just
should we do the portfolio updates and
then we can break for afternoon tea then
we go straight into committee
is everyone okay with that right
um okay 16.1 ewe relationships uh i gave
you very good
it was very good briefing last week
around
mahitahi unfortunately the mahitahi
meeting that was scheduled to happen
today
didn't occur and i know there was a
scheduling um clash
there with another council meeting
council mana did raise that yesterday
and those staff do their best to try and
make sure that
we do have meetings clear but it's
a bit tricky with all the meetings that
are going on this time of year but i
i note that there are interests of other
colleagues that do want to go to those
the next meeting hopefully will occur
but there is a tongue as my
understanding is the reason for
why that meeting was postponed um
there's
uh i went to a meeting with naid to
hariri
kamatula last week around 30 odd there
yeah it was a really interesting meeting
to see ewe dynamics at work
and i was made as we always are made
feel very welcome but i certainly got
told in no uncertain terms of some of
the things that are priorities for them
including the footpath on the other side
of the road
from bramley's to the urapa so i have
asked jared
if that can be considered in terms of
the costing
it's not giving any commitment for it to
be undertaken but
i'd like to know myself what sort of
work would be required because it is
asked at every meeting we go to and i
um i think we need some level of
response or discussion because i
i've been put on um notice that i will
be asked at every meeting about that so
that's fine um i've got a room under
meeting this
well she drawed for this thursday so
with jim and
uh simon i think that's still going to
happen but we'll find out about that
um apart from that just to acknowledge
um as we have done already but day
maraha was
official that was officially conferred
on here
last week so it's a lovely honour for
her and there's
going to be an appropriate recognition
of that at the mirai
uh in december so um uh which
um um we which will find out about the
due course but anyway that's
um really nice that i like the local
very non-level um
uh will recognize that happy to take any
questions
uh can we water management strategy
counselor stuart
uh thank you mr mayor i'll be as quick
as i can um
uh yesterday we had a water zone and
there appears to be a move
from christchurch city for membership on
all the water zone committees and the
regional committee which has caused
quite a level of consternation i would
just be monitoring the email traffic
well
this afternoon um and from what i
understand it was mentioned and now it
seems to have got a bit of
legs a few legs and um from what was
said yesterday
christchurch city may be asking for up
to five
members on the christchurch which melton
water zone committee so
um i'm asking where that has
come from and
what has have i don't think we've had
anything officially
uh but it's certainly out there and
around
so um and been instigated from either
some christchurch councillors
or whatever you bring news councillor
stewart
that
um got very much a thumbs down from um
from the rest of the waimakariri
[Music]
zone committee members but it
it would appear that the regional
regional
committee of ecan
is under review and the with the idea
that um
council members may that
i don't think it has any council members
at the moment or territorial authority
members
there's a move for it and that has been
resist pushed back on so anyway that's
that's
for an item of interest
um yesterday we had um mike bait talking
once more on with pictures areas of the
cam river where
there is no no weed and he's convinced
that
um you know there's spraying occurring
last time he brought this up which was
last
meeting asked sophie to go out with him
and let's map them
and we're just working on that so i
would like to know
where they are and whether there is
anything that immediately strikes us
that is going on there he was also
critical again in fact he's got old
photos but the same about the algae on
the
on pines beach which he says is the
result of our malfunctioning surge
outfall
interestingly yesterday john cook who
used to live down there
and surf for 25 years pre
um the 2006 outfall said he
waded through metre deep um
foam of various colors when he was a
young person
and is still here to tell the tale so
um yeah one of the major
positive things that it came out
yesterday is as you know we've been
through land and water and also through
the water zone committee
asking ecame to put in continuous
monitoring of a whole range of water
quality parameters
on the kaiapoi river and
they have undertaken now to do this and
i think the gear
which is world um some of this gear has
not been
installed anywhere in new zealand before
it is going on the coyote river
end of january february and speaking to
adrian mirror that
yesterday he said after about a year
there should be some data to give an
idea of
how degraded the water
uh the river is on that stretch and um
and from that um try and craft some
solution
he he said he the council ikea and
acknowledges that
the kaipu river is a nutrient sensitive
receiving environment
exhibiting many problems and that he can
can ignore it no longer
so that's some got to be a positive for
all the anecdotal evidence we have
uh how degraded a water body it is we
actually need hard data if we're going
to
make a case for remedial action
um sort of associated with this
is the lower data on
river monitoring uh
it's been brought up many times where
we're not getting the data on water
quality
and that we would hope to
and that's um to enable to really to
measure what's going on in our local
streams the nervous compared to the
national data
so it's been called for a report from
ecan
to have a look in detail about
where are they monitoring what are they
monitoring and of course the new nps
will demand
demanding that there is a more intensive
uh plan for that um
there's various i'll plan change
seven hearings continue and you will
have seen
as i circulated to you the um
the assessment of nitrogen loss that
ecan staff provided to the
uh to the panel really um
significant stuff here and i would
really ask
that um we have a workshop or
have a briefing about what this
could potentially mean um to
the health and wellbeing of this
district and its economic
um growth
uh what else
um oh yes and and arapada right at the
end of the meeting
told us about the statement of claim
over fresh water which is um
he just dropped that in there for our um
uh information and as you've seen it's
all over the
news media throughout the country this
morning so that's about it
and welcome any questions thanks sandra
any questions
thank you uh international relationship
stephanie americans
i had nothing unfortunately to postpone
the meeting at family
to deal with yesterday so i didn't have
that so
and nothing else no one coming and going
that i'm aware of
you you have got work going on with the
patient advisory group which is
traveling well in terms of the
thanks nibble um regeneration council
becky
thank you mr mayor um the
community hub and courtney drive the um
pre-consultation fliers have gone out
today i think it is
to about 80 neighbors just telling them
what what has some
planned there before we get to a full
consultation stage so there's no
surprises for them
and um regen will have a
stall at the christmas carnival in
kaiapoi in december again to
to hand out info on that on that topic
um last week
in the weekend so recently anyway um we
had a rabbit shoot on the
um at the in the east end the
um little buggers were digging holes in
our new playing fields and they got
they got 33 hairs and rabbits in that
chute
um allied to that as the irrigation is
running now
which is making the ground nice and soft
so they can dig their holes more easily
but
um with the the dryness starting to kick
in
um the irrigation running is um is good
the two softball diamonds are finished
and on the 12th of december there is a
demonstration game
i presume that's a saturday was it a
sunday whatever
12th of december anyone who wants to
come down the softball
association putting on demonstration
games
to show the public what it's all about
the pontoons we have our first um
permanent resident has moved in on his
boat to the pontoons
and as of 11 o'clock this morning a
second one
um rang and is coming
and we've got a third one who's uh
probably coming
so we're going to save the the country's
coffers by
returning some massive money to
wellington from our from our red zone um
investment don't hold your breath though
the go bus situation as you are aware
the the um
community board was not in agreement
with the staff recommendation
of um the the police
details just to say that it's gone it's
gone back to
tomorrow thursday night it's gone back
for further discussion with the
community board
thank you thanks council thank you thank
you any questions
uh councilwoman mike thanks
the rabbit shoot um what did you use a
pacific outfit to do that or was it a
volunteer
any other questions for councillor
blechy uh council meetings climate
change and sustainability
she scrambles to finish her report um
okay
so on climate change and sustainability
in the last month
um we have we're currently underway with
the draft climate change policy
which closes our consultation which
closes
on the 13th of november i'm going to be
interviewed on compass fm on friday the
6th so that will be interesting
wish me luck um
the staff submission on the whole of
life embodied emissions reduction
framework which is basically
mb's building for climate change program
that also closes rather sorry closed
no i thought they were going to bring
that to us sorry i've got a wrong date
here
scratch that and
the council submission on reducing the
impact of plastic in our environment
you've just heard that
here today talked about that is due
tomorrow
to be turned in so just as well we've
passed it um
the staff sustainability champions group
met on the 2nd
of october and um
sorry no they did do that they also met
again
um i'll just skip forward and get to the
next bit about that sorry um the
elected member sustainability strategy
steering group
a bit of mouthful um had its inaugural
meeting on the 15th of october
with mr blackie not sitting at that end
of the table but um
definitely there and present and i mean
i'd like to think that that got off to a
pretty good start i'm quite happy to see
some of the cool ideas that um
that came out of that and i think that
it really bodes well for the future
yes some neat ideas started to flow
before we were even really ready to
capture ideas
and also just the selection of people
that we've got on there
and what they can bring to the table i
think it's a it's a good mix so i'm
really looking forward to seeing what we
can do with that
um on the 28th of october there was an
eco workshop which the sustainability
champions um put together
and um the internal staff sustainability
champions group met the next day
and gosh we discussed they discussed
some really
broad um things there um including like
various electric transport options staff
carpooling options
um adding climate change considerations
to our um
organizations compliance schedules like
whenever they go through a checklist of
you know your demolition or you're
looking at a building compliance or
you're just
basically trying to sort of um socialize
the idea of sustainability and climate
change
which is embedded in really everything
that the council does not just from a
reporting
point of view but also just just to try
to sort of have that cultural change
and also
incorporating sustainability
considerations into all the catering so
i know some some areas have done that
like for instance i know sarah has gone
through with with our catering and
and made those more sustainable but
not all departments have that happening
so which
surprised me i thought a lot of the
catering so yeah
yeah well just yeah there is a lot and
um yeah even even things like that the
three bin
implementation progress like you know
that was something that we've been
looking for
waiting for for for ages we know that
those bins have been sitting there
they've only just um linda's managed to
get them all rolled out in all the all
of the temporary accommodation but first
what they had to do was get the
the external bins because obviously
all of the places where our staff are
not buildings that we own so of course
then you know there are implications for
the property for instance like
once we leave as an example um the
landlord will then have the rating
implications of having those
those bins so you know and just kind of
negotiating things like that but
before they could have the internal bins
like those there
um we needed to have the external bins
for it to be carted to
otherwise it's all very nice separating
it out but
where do you put it whenever you've
whenever you've got it so you know just
just really kind of bare basic things
that
need to be implemented which um kind of
surprises me actually there's a lot of
work to be done there but but
i'm pleased to see that there are some
people in various areas of our staff
that are passionate about it
um and i will stop waffling with this
last thing which is the 25th of november
will be my first
ccc coastal hazards working group
meeting as
an observer so so that will be
interesting i wonder what i shall
observe but it's not it's nice that
you've been
we've been invited exactly yeah
i thought that was a new group but it's
actually been going for quite some time
and
they've given me a stack of minutes to
review um from previous ones so um yeah
that should be quite interesting i've
just received those in the last day or
two so
thanks thank you it's a very full report
thank you um
just to let you know that there's a
paper going to canterbury mural
forum to australia to our climate change
working group on friday
which is a subgroup of the canterbury
mural forum and uh and then
i've asked that the be considered that
the portfolio holders of respective
councils like yourself
this number out there they actually are
relatively homeless i don't mean that
nastily but
it would be really great to bring your
expertise
um
so that's going to the climate change
group on friday which
um i cheer and that'll go to the
canterbury mural forum for its view
um the following week or whenever it
next meets so just to let you know that
i'm following through with that but
it would be great to see that why their
expertise have a home
um and hopefully that's endorsed on
friday
any questions of nikki sandra just
really on
the argument you've just um brought up
about and climate change
the biodiversity champions exercise
which was
instigated by the meal forum i had a
and i'm your representative i had um
a an email from landfarm about um
getting together so is there within the
mayoral forum
a biodiversity honestly i don't know and
how is that
um one i don't think all the territorial
authorities have pointed yet but they
they will be so here's another group of
about 10 nobody people
what happens with you know i'm not i'm
not aware of that group but
um you know jim is investigated by the
mural forum
so can you inquire i'll look into it yep
thank you any other questions of nikki
thanks nikki
okay so i have no questions there's no
urgent general business so um now move
that we
um item 19 which is that we go into
public excluded
seconded by council atkinson now the
click and the reasons um
below the dimension there so um i'll put
the recommendation all those in favor
please say aye
contrary to clear that carried so we're
now in public excluded
at this point have a junior meeting
um i just thought it was easy to do it
now so if we're back about 10 past
four so um my understanding is adrian's
got some
some chocolate biscuits out there so
thank you adrian
you